1960 le ciel de paris se couvre de fumée
usine chauffage voiture
ces trois éléments sont responsables de
la pollution de l'air et faudra
peut-être changer le style de notre et
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
même les présentations de mode ne
gagneront pas une anticipation un brin
humoristique mais ce n'est pas de la
fiction
déjà dans les années 60 les spécialistes
craignaient les effets de la pollution
atmosphérique tout particulièrement les
gaz d'échappement des voitures
sont-ils cancérigènes chez l'homme on ne
peut pas l'affirmer mais en revanche on
peut les suspectés d'être à l'origine de
au moins en partie de l'augmentation de
fréquence du cancer du poumon ont révélé
les statistiques appliquées aux deux ou
trois dernières décades des laboratoires
capte et étudie l'air dans la capitale
le principal coupable identifier c'est
le benzopyrène rejeté par certains
industriels par les voitures diesel
toujours préoccupant aujourd'hui en 1963
le gouvernement décide d'agir
l'arrêté que monsieur marc jacquet
ministre des travaux publics vient de
signer prescrite il qu'aucun véhicule ne
devra désormais maîtres de fumée
nettement un thé ou opaque déjà des
sanctions à l'époque et un air de déjà
vu aussi pour la solution envisagée
il faudra mettre des épurateurs ou tout
autre système qui permettra une
meilleure carburation
il faut savoir que
dispositif entraînant une augmentation
du coût des voitures mais je suis
convaincu que les citoyens accepteront
de payer pour préserver leur sang en
attendant toujours dans les années 60 la
pollution dans les grandes villes
françaises pèsent sur les citadins soit
en quatre ans en mai jamais vu l'air de
paris au qui m'aurait jamais lire
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les dégâts de la pollution
atmosphérique sur la santé sont reconnus
elle serait responsable de 48000 meurent
chaque année selon santé publique france
[Musique]